right thirty minutes and three two one
hello everyone welcome to what we call
hot breath live maybe don't mind me mark
a quick rub and tuck this is perfect
this is how we're gonna go viral this is
our big break people it's mo your gal
must be so proud
oh yeah what's the tiny penis no come on
I've listened to Tuesday's of stories I
know the deal medium so people in the
comments that is a great icebreaker so
you don't have to ask that question
anymore don't ask mark how big his penis
is he just told us so go ahead and start
commenting with you with your questions
and we're gonna get this going but I
have to ask you first
Marcus you you told a lot of cool
stories about your work with Seinfeld in
terms of like the behind the scenes
stuff but you know hot breath is like a
comedy education show and I'd be
wondering what you learned from more of
like the craft side or how he operated
that you've kind of applied to what you
do now mm-hmm
good question there fatty I would say
he's uh he's such a workhorse
he's too he's almost a perfectionist to
a fault where it takes him a while to
make new material because he's such a
nut about the meticulous wording and the
choices and the order and everything
mm-hmm
so in a way it's almost a flaw but it's
also what makes his material so great so
uh what I learned was he had this great
thing about writing because nobody likes
to write it's a pain in the ass it sucks
but he said if you turn the music off
turn the TV off put the phone away and
just stare at an idea you think it's
funny your brain will get so miserable
that it'll have to crack the code on it
does that make sense huh you know like
if you're stuck in a room you
find something to do because your brain
doesn't want to be bored so if you stare
at a joke for a long enough like the
premise and then the feeling of like
alright this sucks I want to go do
something else
if you hang in there your brain will get
so bored it'll make it happen it'll make
it work so you'll just like physically
sit there and stare at it like written
on the page type deal
totally yeah and every fiber in your
beam says pull out jerk up watch TV go
gay but you stick with it and your brain
will come up with something fascinating
and if you look as material you can see
that he did that he's got this joke
about golf I don't give away his
material hmm but he's like golf I don't
understand golf you know why guys go
golf cuz I need to be alone that's what
golf stands for go out leave family
funny joke but you can tell he came up
with that joke from just staring at the
[ __ ] golf that word gol F and that's
how he got there very cool so that
you'll do that now I try I mean I'm not
as disciplined as him cuz uh you know I
got I got all these toys I got a moped I
got a I got a lady naked next to me you
know so it's hard but he's a 65 year old
Jew and he's willing to do it yeah this
actually can go into the first question
from Charlie Harper you brought up Jews
mark what's your favorite Jewish hmm
well I mean I got to go to the source
I gotta go Groucho hmm it's Groucho
Larry David there's somewhere someone
neck-and-neck
great neck-and-neck with those two so uh
I guess I go Larry because he's alive
but the old-timer is a big old Julius
marks Groucho
yeah that's a you have him as your
Twitter header photo two with the with
the gals oh yeah that's right yeah he's
just so funny he was the first guy to do
it that way and just joke after joke and
mm-hmm he's Woody Allen and Bill Cosby's
idol which changes over the years but
that's pretty good yeah this guy so
there's a couple too quick Groucho lines
yeah one he's director is directing a
movie some guy
director his name's Andy wood and they
go hey will you cuz Groucho kept cutting
up and he goes look I can't make that
actors out of clay and he goes well
apparently it can't make directors out
of wood pretty quick yeah yeah second he
was at a restaurant in LA and a priest
comes up to and goes mr. Groucho I want
to bother you he's eating a bowl of soup
and he goes I don't know buddy but I
just want to thank you for putting so
much joy into the world and Groucho
looks up and goes I just want to thank
you for taking so much out come on quick
comedy comedy indeed this question
Dylan O'Neal who's actually a Toronto
comedian by way of Ireland so he wonders
how much of the greats have you studied
and how do you break their sets down mmm
well studied is a tough question I mean
I've watched everything watched all of
carlin watch all of prior you name it
but I don't know about study that's a
good question I get is this cat watching
counter study yeah yeah I think that's
what he means by study is like you're
watching but when you're watching a
comedian
how are you analyzing them what are you
looking for well there's a lot of real
here line it gets a huge Levin to go why
to take an elem or even you say a line
onstage go why did that click that
wasn't what I intended to laugh but I
got a laugh so I think with something
like that you gotta just sit there and
just break it down and that's kind of
why comedy is magical because sometimes
just can't figure it out so you're like
you hear a laugh and you're always
wondering why what do they do is it what
they said or is it how they said it type
deal yeah yeah cuz usually go that got a
laughs it was a misdirect or it was a
pun or you thought he's gonna say this
he said that but sometimes it's just a
funny thing in a funny rhythm and it
just tickles that taint well how are you
able to evoke laugh in your own certain
style because Dylan actually had a
little follow-up detail of I'd love to
know his process because his jokes are
so quick and sharp and easy to follow
and the punchlines are gold Wow well
being honest I have zero faith in the
audience I assume audiences are all
incredibly unfunny and incredibly dumb
and I have to I spell out every joke
because there's other words worse than
having a great idea and then them not
getting it so you've got to make them
understand it you know so I say it over
and over a million times and I just keep
trying to simplify simplify simplify and
take out everything you don't need and
shorten it up because I also have no
faith in people's attention span hmm so
it's just years of hammering it through
like a funny filter or a simple filter
is there a TV on or sound uh only see it
wait is your gal in there watching oh
yeah okay don't worry about it I don't
want to I don't want to block you for
later she's gonna bake you did that
silly podcast and they tell me I don't
know that's how she sounds or not I only
knows all right from your Instagram
video of the corona Lingus I believe it
was oh yeah you nailed it
true story well when you're talking
about like editing your joke in the
audience not understanding it when you
say a joke one way and then you're like
they're not understanding it how the how
are you then editing it down what are
the things are manipulating to make them
understand it in the future keep it
simple I always think about McDonald's
okay what would McDonald's do you know
if this has got to be it's got to appeal
to everybody and it's got to be easy to
understand like a website you never go
on a website you're like glad you read
legal jargon you're like what the [ __ ]
is this I think you've got to just make
it so it's buttons and letters and
colors
you know just easy-peasy to figure out
since you want to walk in that store and
get it so it's like maybe they don't
understand the premise so you need to be
more clear on what it is you're even
trying to say with the premise of course
I mean look at Chris Rock he repeats his
premise three times you know women can't
go back in lifestyle they can't go back
in life the women that he touches him
making sure you get in you know exactly
saying nice simple is better
oh you got to keep it simple nothing
worse have been confusing as a comic all
right Justin born oval what is your
opinion of the live stream shows that
are popping up online would you
recommend starting one or waiting until
this craziness is over now you got to do
what you got to do just e you know get
out there keep saying have an outlet so
about having an outlet you know we used
to get up on stage twice a night three
times a night now that just completely
wiped out so you got to figure something
out so if you want to do it do it I
don't know if there's much to gain from
it but we should Yap and your gums and
scheduling something it gives you a
little hope have you I say do have you
done any of them uh one or two there I
think they're dumb I'd rather do this
yeah that's what I've been asking every
comic thing has come on here is like a
lot of us right now we're like what are
we even what do we do as comedians you
know and a lot of people are saying like
Mike Canon and Jacob Williams was on
here today and they were all we're just
creating a bunch of content while Sean
Patton is on here saying he's doing more
of these live stream pop-up shows and
stuff like that what are you doing I'm
doing this I'm making videos I'm
tweeting like a madman I'm writing like
a madman so for me it's all about
staying funny and I don't feel like
those those live shows are funny that
really that funny cuz it's all about the
laugh I need that response from an
audience so it's it's tough but you know
I'm not knocking them do what you got to
do but I like pods and I like the
interaction I don't feel like I'm
getting a real reaction from those nice
all right yeah exactly it's so early
into this quarantine that it's still a
lot of like trial and error you know
right right and that Sean Patton had
said he did one early on that was just
like him in comics and then he did it
one like the day before our interview
where it was like comics with an actual
like audience of like 15 people on zoom'
like it was really so they're they're
growing getting a little more
sophisticated but okay it's still yeah
there may be a
lay or something it's still not as well
there's an audience then that's
different I was like I was thinking it
was just you and a guy mm-hmm
so maybe I'll do it okay I'm sure
eventually yeah um
this is it's no Joe Rogan but it'll
definitely you know now you might have
talked me into it well this next one
comes from Liam Harvey it is uh what's
your favorite kind of queef I like a
long slappy one just like a blue those
are the best when it really gets the
arrow all right and less importantly
where's a good place to learn joke
writing techniques any books slash
anything I can read that's a good
question I don't you could read the
comedy Bible but it's not great hmm I
think go online there's a youtube video
online of Seinfeld writing a joke and
the New York Times did it that was
pretty good but again it's it's like
boxing you got to get in the ring right
it's hard to learn you got to try and
fail and tweak it and try it or you got
to try it on regular people at your work
or your family your friends it it's
almost a two to tango kind of thing you
know it's like saying uh it's like just
sing it you get a can I learn to be sexy
now you got to go try it be sexy and
fail and you know you can't just jump
right in you need the response so
without knowing whether it's good or not
it's hard to get better that makes sense
yeah there was a there's a Greg Dean
book that was like step by step to stand
up but still no one I've ever read but
it was good at breaking down one-liners
in terms of like how do I gotta find
your premise how to set it up how to
misdirect it so it was good in the early
years of just finding maybe the
mechanism behind creating a joke but
yeah I still have to say it on stage to
know yeah or to even a human being
something right yeah exactly
look but listen to hot breath podcast
it's a great one
Liam battle or just listen to Steven
Wright to meet you Martin Mitch Hedberg
and
see what they did and go why did that go
that way well you know figure it out all
right Quinn Fitzgerald says oh love the
pod all right thank you Quinn oh hey
he's talking about which one you talking
to to scare hot breath I don't know what
you want he's talking about good
question I will say both we're of the
same ilk uh and he also asked how do you
know when you should move to New York
for comedy mmm
I don't know it's like I want a baby
there's no wrong or right time I think
just go just go hmm
you'd get 10 minutes together that you
like although I went with 10 minutes I
was like just kills everywhere I'm gonna
show up to New York or what's gonna blow
me bomb for two years so yeah I would go
sooner better than later yeah just kind
of jump in not right now but wait for
this pandemic well yeah yeah but
otherwise just jump in yeah and uh Sean
Patton actually had fun insight into
just like move here but just understand
nothing's overnight and that you're
gonna be doing these rough open mikes
and it's gonna be uphill but if you want
to do comedy then it's just part of the
process yeah you could be a great pole
vaulter but New York is the Olympics so
now you're coming in the Olympic camp
and you gotta have to step it up yep
all right Oh Jason P Leonard he said hey
comedy ah Lenny he runs some great shows
in Louisiana ray chose Thomas mattel ski
what inspires you when comedy kicks you
in the teeth again and again whoo-wee
well the funny thing is the teeth
kicking is what keeps you coming back
because it hurts so bad
that it motivates you to go I got to do
that again just to feel better and then
that one could kick you in the balls too
but it just every now that you give that
one good one that you're like all right
all right all right I'm good but you're
only as good you're less and it stings
and it hurts but what else can you do it
maybe just we've chosen this is it you
know you got dumped before you didn't
give up women what have you found to
like in those low moments where like you
did bomb or something didn't work out
what if what did you find
was helpful in you overcoming that
faster whoo well you got to go back to
the notebook and retool and and go go
hard go harder and then because it's so
scary that feeling it's so painful that
it makes you motivates you to work
harder and go back and then you're like
all right now when I go back on stage
I'll be ready yeah it's almost motivated
the faster you get back on stage the
better you'll feel type deal yes keep
moving just keep fighting exactly
totally all right mr. Leonard he
followed up with a question do you think
a lot of comics on any level won't come
back once the virus is over I sure hope
so we need a good we need a good
whooshing the world but yeah for sure I
mean yeah there's so many even in
January you see a huge influx because
everyone's got their resolutions and
then by late February they're gone
because they really oh there's no money
in this is a lot of work I'm losing my
nights so it's this is gonna push out a
lot of comics and I I'm I'm happy about
it because you know there's not enough
stage time for everybody let's be honest
and look everybody can do it everybody
should have the right to do comedy but
it's not for everybody and if you're
just jerking off and having a fun hobby
that's great but some of us are buying
food with this so I don't know do what
you want but leave it to the passionate
yeah how are you making money right now
by the way also
well this pays I know I I get my podcast
is bringing in a lot of dough I'm not
about to sell this special hopefully
that I just best rum so that'll that'll
be a night gender change oh yeah sound
exchange every time I they play my album
on Sirius
that's a nice chimp so I'm just living
off a royalty basically mm-hmm so when
what's what's the deal with the special
when did you what's what's going on with
that well it took a little longer to
edit
because my editor had a snafu and then
we have a network involved and then they
pulled out now we got a new network so
there's all kinds of hiccups but we're
back and it looks great and I'm proud of
it and I'm happy with it so it should
come out soon but I need a little time
to promote now that's all done I thought
was gonna come out yesterday but
everything fell apart so now it's coming
out in like two three weeks but I just
because I need some promotion time oh
wow okay where'd you filming at Hilda
the theater in LA called the dynasty
typewriter okay we sold it out and we
were like was a pretty place we might as
well shoot here last minute we just it
all came together and I'm thank Jesus
praise I love that I filmed it before
this [ __ ] happen Wow and is this one
of those specials you like paid for
yourself with hopes to sell it oh yeah
yeah oh yeah totally the Sam Morril
model yeah it seems to be the move yeah
I want to get him on here to talk about
how he did his whole thing and then
released it actually through Comedy
Central's YouTube and all that it's very
yeah oh yeah interesting angle yeah
seems to be the new world order and
these other companies like he's one of
the best comics and Netflix is stupid
for not putting them on but they just
think there's they want shiny star
[ __ ] which i get it's a business Hey
all right Alton coming up next Trent
Bab for writing when you write multiple
punchlines for one joke do you tend to
go with the one with the most surprise
or the one that flows the best woo now
you see that once that's a tough one
because you should go with the one that
it's a compromise of the best laughs and
that you feel good about it's gonna fit
you you got to have integrity and go
with it because sometimes you get a
happy line they tails but you go hey
that's probably done a million times B
that's easy it's only getting live
because I say [ __ ] or jizz or whatever
so you got to find the nice integrity
line between this kills and I I like it
I approve of this hmm so then the one
that with the flow
oh the flow just gonna happen you can't
just have a good punch line and change
the flows and the punch line will change
so I wouldn't worry about the flow or
whatever I would worry about how you
feel about it and if it gets it's got to
get a huge laughs - it seems like if you
feel better about the joke you'll be
able to deliver it more consistently
totally totally and the more confidence
you have behind it like you know when
you're but to deliver a punch line you
go this is gonna kill mmm-hmm that's
what you want it's almost like you know
when sometimes you shoot a basketball
and right where leaves your finger you
go that's gonna swish even before it
hits midair you know it's going in
that's how a joke should feel when you
tell it how long did you prepare for
this new special how long were you
writing I think I wrote the thing within
two years but if I'd done another year
of just polishing and then another you
yeah has six months of adding tags cuz
you gotta almost fall out of love of a
bit where you can see it clearly yeah
you know like we've all heard a woman be
like my boyfriend's beautiful you look
at him he's a fat piece of garbage
but in her eyes she loves him so much
that he seems attractive sometimes you
have that with jokes you know you're
like this joke I love it so much I'm so
proud of it but it's not that great of a
joke so you almost need to step back
from your own material for a while just
to see that the realness of it you know
how accurate is or how funny it actually
is and are you your discipline with
writings but are you disciplined with
like recording your set and reviewing
your set as well and like that process
pretty good the beginning you know if
the joke is new I'll listen to it a
hundred times but if once it starts
working I just kind of put it over in
the killing pile cool and I don't really
listen to it anymore but you gotta
listen to new alright Charlie Harper
first comic you saw live Oh me uh Jesus
I thought he was would say his first
kind of guy so alive I saw this guy and
we talked of real comics or like open my
kurz probably a name worthy comics
jeez maybe Seinfeld that's so simple and
oh one in Baton Rouge Dayton a gal she
got me tickets for a birthday present I
still remember it he ran out he had the
suit on it was incredible I still
remember some of the bits I saw George
Carlin shortly after that on a casino
and in Mississippi not a great set but
something cool to see I'm glad as long
as he died shortly after so yeah those
are probably the two big ones that stand
out nice all right Zach Lyman where was
your first headliner gig
first headlining gig was at a place
called the Howlin wolf in New Orleans
and it was like wasn't even a real
headlining gig was like six comics and I
went last right yeah yeah
those are bass marks those are
milestones though in our career sure I
was I was happy about I was excited or
my name was on the flyer you know 12
people showed up it's a huge room that
fits 512 peelers they're just you know I
bombed my ass off but it was still a
fill a big moment my brother showed up
and nobody nobody liked it but it was
something all right
Liam Harvey how do you get away with
riskier bits like your pedophile bit
grape juice he said oh thanks
that bit took months and months took
almost a year to get that bit to work
because it's so dark and you know such a
touchy subject no pun intended with the
kid touching but it's so tufted like you
had to work that bit out but you got a
also factor in that they're terrified
you know so it's tough to get those
jokes to work so you've got a I almost
have to tweak those to perfection in
your apartment before you can actually
get a laugh at it the joke has to be
pitch perfect before it'll work because
the subject matter is so edgy how do you
get it right
Oh in your apartment alone without an
audience because he still bombed with it
you got to just suck it up and bomb with
it and just get little bits of
information from the audience every time
it
it's like alright it did a little bit if
I say it that way if I say it faster it
does better or if I just lean into it
it got a little bit better and then over
time just with those little clues I
could get it to work 100% but it took a
lot of trial and error of just Guinea
pigging that bit over and over let me
try it little this way let me try that
way we tried it and it took forever but
I finally got it what makes you continue
to pursue a joke like that instead of
just saying I it's it's useless I'll
throw it away everything in your body's
like throw it away you're bombing you're
you're throwing your whole set off
because this pedophile joke is freaking
people hooked but if you believe in it
and you run it by comics that's where
comics come in handy because comics just
see through they don't see the [ __ ]
they see though this is a good bit I
like the idea here they're not just
listening to the you know oh the
buzzword they actually hear the bit for
what it is so I think you got to use
your friends on that one gotcha alright
we're uh we've got about six minutes
left kids so we're gonna bump them in
here
mic fountain best ways to recognise
sharpen and develop your persona slash
voice oh man I gotta tell you that's a
good question when I was coming up I
asked everybody that question for Pete
Holmes and asked him I asked Tom papa I
asked everybody when I would start now
because I was like what the hell is your
voice what is that why is why is
everybody found theirs and I haven't
found mine and somebody told me I forgot
who but somebody gave me the great
advices look at all your jokes that work
and find the common link between all
those jokes and that's probably your
voice why do you keep going back to
these why is this subject matter touched
on a lot why is this like this why did
you pick that beti or whatever it is and
that helped me and listening yourself
and you go oh that's a that's a joke I
would tell or you listen to your friends
I go that's such a Marc joke that's and
you're like really and then you go okay
so what the hell's Marc what the hell is
that you know and just it's all about
clues and remembering everything take it
all in so for me I figure out eventually
that my stick is
well it's basically saying if this is
like that then why isn't this like that
and that's why we'll act yeah
nice I don't see color well then I'm
black no you're not you know just by
inconsistencies all right Vic Cedeno he
said comedy
Avik next paper up michael vick Howick
dorias sorry no you're good
I would I would play the game with you
but I want to make sure we get all these
questions no no you're right yeah in in
a longer interview I'll tag them up with
you how long after you write a joke do
you try it on stage and so you review
notes before going on stage or edit
after well this two questions I think
it's um how long after you write a joke
we try it on stage and then do your
notes before going on or do you just
edit after ah good question there Vikki
I write if I feel good about a joke but
I've written I'll do it that night
sometimes I'll write it on the train on
the way to a show and feel like oh this
is this is this is a jackpot guaranteed
laughs I'll try it and it doesn't always
work probably nine out of ten times it
doesn't but if I feel good about it I'll
try it sometimes I have an idea in the
shower and I go this is big and you
gotta like take it apart and sometimes
that takes weeks before you bring it on
the stage because it's such a complex
idea that you got to simplify before you
bring it out to the masses and to I will
look at my notes till them millisecond
before I grab the microphone I'm walking
on the stage looking at my notes
you gotta look at your notes I read
something when I was a kid that if you
study right before the test you have
like if you like you read through your
study material [ __ ] before your test
you'll you'll do like 28% better and
it's the same with your jokes if you
look through it especially new stuff it
helps boom alright Sean Murphy I've
heard things I've heard for years that
you need to be able to perform clean
comedy I try hard to write clean meaning
I don't curse a lot but my subject
matter always ends up adult what's your
opinion on clean comedy
hate to say it Shawnee Murph
Doug but it is very helpful very almost
almost necessary I mean even David tells
like the funniest kind of planning he's
got a [ __ ] jokes and his his he's got
clean he can write clean he can do it so
I think it's imperative if you want to
do balland you want to do all these late
nights you got to have it so it's a good
way to get in the door I'm not saying
it's you I'm not saying it's your voice
or your path rather for forever but I
think it's good to have and [ __ ] it suck
it up and and try to make it work like
let's say you're an amazing wrestler and
you want to do the MMA you got to learn
boxing you got a box a little so have it
in your corner you know I'm not saying
it's got to be your future career what's
the opposite of temporary permanent
thank you say your permanent world but
try it knock it out and it's harder it
is harder I will say as a comic I can
admit clean is harder dirty is easier
about saying dirty is bad I'm not saying
dirty tack but it's easier because sex
will get a laugh cursing we're gonna
laugh so challenge yourself by trying to
write some clean yeah and if you didn't
have clean you wouldn't be able to open
for a Seinfeld exactly exactly and I
trust me I just sift through albums of
stuff mm-hmm
to find the cleanest [ __ ] that's like
his level clean and I'm tell you what
I'm glad ahead it all right dos mas mis
amigos Charlie Harper what do you feel
is the biggest drawback that keeps the
bigger distributors from buying specials
well I'll tell you what Netflix told me
okay they said we got a lot of honkies a
lot of straight whitey but if you're
selling out like 2,000 seats or more
we'll have you because that means they
can guarantee views so be a minority get
in a wheelchair be fat have something or
get famous and then go have become a
stand-up
or just get a following if you get a
following on your own they become some
youtube queef that'll help you know go
get a huge youtube numbers and then send
your special they'll buy it they're just
they're just business people there's
their suits yeah they just want numbered
um they want money they want views so if
you don't want to do it the long way
that's your route go viral
then do comedy alright
Trent Babb Seinfeld told you to move
around more on stage do you do you bring
that advice to all your gigs are just
the larger ones now I do it at all of
them why the hell not cuz I wouldn't do
it but when he told me that I was like I
what the hell this guy's old fashioned
he's you know he's out of touch and I
did it and my set went from a b-minus to
an a-plus so he was right and I'm glad I
took his advice and I'm glad I applied
it because why the hell not if it works
on a theater it'll work on a club so
what did you try I'm not jumping around
like what did you tell just everything I
used to walk out plant my feet at a
theater stage and just deliver my joke
standing there and they went well but
you walk out and you walk all the way to
one side walk all the way they'll do
like a Chris Rock thing start saying the
n-word everything and you will that
crowd can't take their eyes off of you
and they're mesmerized and now now
they're so messed up that they're
engaged more and listening more so
they're gonna hear every joke every word
every punch so that equals more or less
boom alright and the final question here
I'm gonna squeeze in skip because I met
him in a Lafayette Louisiana I did when
a Jason shows last year and he bought a
hot breath shirt so I want to let him
decide the final question
see you buy merch you get paid in the
end so a skip asks how long will you
keep a bit / work on it till you drop it
especially if you love the bit but it's
not getting the response you want by hey
you got to drop them greg Giraldo said
you got to kill your babies it's hard
but I've seen comics in New York doing
the same
bit and it bombs every goddamn time and
they keep doing it and it makes you look
worse and it also makes you look crazy
like you're going what are you trying to
get out of this bit it never has worked
once get rid of it but I know it's hard
we're so attached and we took the time
to write it so it's so hard to let it go
but if you truly believe in it I would
put it aside as I said fall out of love
with it or become a better writer over
time and then revisit it and you can
really look at it from a clear eye and
go that's what I was missing that's it I
missed that one little angle and I
changed the whole bit so you really
believe in it put it in the drawer come
back in a year boom mark Normand
everyone let's give him a round of
applause thank you mark for coming back
on hot breath man I know we we had an
interview planned while you were in
Atlanta and then Corona brought us two
crazy so I know I'll be back it's
already rescheduled I'll be back I think
in the beginning of next year I'll have
some new material the special come out
listen to the pod yes like we never left
yeah everyone go support mark Tuesdays
with stories the podcast and when that
special comes out man anything we can do
here at hop Brett to help you man please
don't hesitate good love you yeah share
it spread the word go gay spread your
cheeks anal flea semen Rosella
thanks gay mark Normand thanks for being
at the hot breath averse my man thank
you
hey what's the title of your special out
to lunch out to lunch
shrimp Babb at the buzzer mark Normand
have a good night stay safe out there my
man Jews